let's go ahead and test for April.
Two to five. Seven to ten. It's a bit not.
Okay and we don't need the lines. Okay so get out of April, let's take a look.
Cool. First of April. Inflation rate in jolts. From a structural direction
standpoint. Parish water flow.
No. April was when all the the tariff craziness was here as well. I think it's
April third. The reciprocal tariff plan was announced. No.
9.45 wins the second. Yeah this is when today's when the reciprocal tariff is
announced. Again this technically makes the structure really annoying to read.
And then looking for lungs don't get them. New York is nothing. Okay we're
still looking
for lungs. It is Friday 4th which is NFP. Again. No entry. I'm not going to
trade New York
session. Monday the 7th. We have balance of trade. So be looking for lungs. But
only
below that age session. Looking for lungs but only below that age session.
Already finished.
This is the 8th. Now we can look for New York lungs. So already below. We have
a low sweep.
We have a low. Reverse or potentially.
One. No.
Make sure on the M1 structure here to be honest with you one second.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Sometimes it can be annoying.
Okay, so we are bearish M1, and we're looking for lungs.
So we need to see this high bed broken, which is the high that I thought was in
control the whole time, but whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, just need to confirm.
Okay, hold on a minute.
So, we shift bullish here.
Not my favorite type of price action.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Got it.
As you can see this, what used to be probably in 2024,
I mean, in the beginning of 2025, I would like at beginning of 2025,
maybe like a seven, eight pip stop, 2024, like four, five pip stop.
2025 during the tariffs in Trump, 16 pip stop.
All right, like it's, it is actually such a different market environment.
I used US stops low, by stop, south door, and, I mean,
M15, structural high, it's up here.
All of that.
9.0 tug.
All of that for that.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We have inflation rates.
Inflation rates, yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Confused as to why price did that at 9.30.
When there was news eight thirty.
I was just making sure that the times and stuff were okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's unfortunate.
No.
Fair enough.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Of course.
And honestly, you might see me take some time like this in the live market.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And at that time.
And like I said, there's a good chance that I probably would have taken this in
the live market.
Probably entry in this cluster, remember when price comes back into this level
and trades away from it.
That's me basically going to break even.
So still reading the same order flow.
If you know I'm trying to get out.
If I'm taking this trade now, my stop loss going here.
But if I was already in the trade, my stop loss will also be on here.
Because my theory would be that price trades through this level here.
There's a higher probability that price is just going to trade through the
enticing.
So it makes sense.
From a target perspective.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Pretty much break even.
The entire leg becomes negated for me personally.
And that's a break even.
The New York Thursday 17 housing starts interest rates.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, good magic.
As you can see, trust me like the thing I'm most impressed about with this
playbook is the trade management.
I don't really know even how to optimize it.
I feel like it's optimized for a good level.
Maybe take profit levels, but I don't know.
This is a, I also didn't see that as well by the way.
That's a bunch of liquidity.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Somewhere over here.
I don't know.
It's a call.
It's the answer there.
The trend at this point is the trending.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Kind of.
Cool.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
This goes from 1% to 0.2%.
It's like always risk management.
How quickly can I remove risk from this trade?
That's the most important thing I care about.
Because if I can't lose money, then like I'm good.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Boom.
Risk management.
And in this case is a good management.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Don't think so.
Which is fine.
Like not every single trade is going to be.
I mean technically, so it's kind of twofold.
One.
Instead of taking the full 1%, which I would have taken,
I took 0.2.
Obviously I could have had my stop below this low.
And I would have taken any, but still would have taken 0.2.
Now the thesis that if my stop goes here,
then it price trades from here, and the likelihood is it's still going to trade
to my stop loss.
It still takes true, but it doesn't take the actual swing low.
So.
Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The woman is technically still bearish right now.
The moment is technically bullish right now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Not an ideal set up.
Eighteens.
No news on a Friday.
Interesting.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Today, I know I was in for that last trade.
No.
Which is fine.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay.
The, like I said, it is a little bit, once it's 17.
Let's look at this again.
Okay.
I don't like the stop placement. Not a huge fan.
This is the M1.
Does it even shift bullish?
Okay. M1 shifts bullish from here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Not a huge fan with that stop placement just in the middle of nowhere.
Again, apologies.
Recording with a cold is not for the faint hide.
Not the greatest approach actually in general to be honest with you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's take a bird's view.
Okay.
No news.
Again, no news in a Friday is weird.
Am I?
I'm sorry.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
M5.
Still a 1 to 40.
Like I could have spent so long on this trade.
I shouldn't be overseeing it like this, but I just don't know about stop
placement.
Like it's quite an unorthodox trade, like in an ideal world, I don't want to
stop under here, but then it becomes like a 15-11 pip stop all the way to here
is just AR.
I want to be able to put my 5R off the table quickly.
I'm just going to risk it.
It is what it is.
It's not a bigger deal.
We're already up 20%.
It's not that big of a deal.
Could have just used this order, but.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
At least we can get risk off the table.
I should have used this order block here because that would be break even right
now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There's 5R.
Not a huge fan of the stop placement as I've said 100 times.
That's the weekend as well, which is a pretty annoying thing.
I want to move stops to break even just because it's over the weekend.
One half happened over that weekend.
Geez Louise.
That's ridiculous.
I ended up getting super lucky to be honest with you.
In some sense, like.
Yeah.
Again, I don't like one trade amount into that.
That powerful one I'm going to do is I'm going to bring it back and.
I'm going to take off.
I'm going to take off 50% of 5R.
Even though it may not be made up to manage it like that.
But I don't want that amount of return to be.
I should be into this one trade.
I mean, like I would obviously you're going to have big winners.
And that's fine, like I'm all for big winners.
But when I'm back to my data, I don't want.
I don't want one trade to skew data.
But obviously like I'm all for taking winners.
But this is not really a.
It's also not like an A plus set up type of thing.
Plus I'm always going to take 5R anyway.
Like obviously holding trade up the weekend.
It can be different.
I probably would just have stops to break even.
And in this type of scenario.
Hands if you've got magic key set up or not, but I would.
I don't know.
You may have held the full full volume unintentionally.
But yeah.
I would rather have it like that.
I spent so much time on that trade.
Just keep things rolling.
This is a.
New York continuation from London.
Because the change of character just happens here like this is.
I wouldn't even consider it a New York continuation of London.
Let me know what to consider this up.
London sweeps Asia, we tried to long from here.
I would have liked to have longed here.
But we couldn't get the long there because it was bearish and one.
So we waited until M one and shifted.
But then it had the only kind of plausible area of interest a trade from was
here.
This kind of final cluster before the shift.
And it.
Kind of is a continuation from London.
It's more like.
London sweeps Asia and New York continuation is.
It's a weird schematic.
Also a New York continuation from London area of interest.
I mean it still is like I wanted to trade.
I originally wanted to trade along here.
Couldn't get it.
New York opens trades back into this region.
It expands outwards and then just plain continuation.
Like New York continuation from London area of interest.
Point of interest.
Again like.
I don't really know if I'm not to consider.
Probably this broad.
New York trend is trending structure flow is this.
Yeah.
Wait is it?
Nope.
There's no news.
Um.
Probably argue that it's a flag for review.
It's not really a like.
Stand itself in some sense.
Okay.
Let's move on from this process.
I spent like 15 minutes here.
That would be a New York continuation.
Part 2 something in the middle.
Like this M15 body.
M5 has inverted.
Probably go with the M5 inverted.
There you go.
Good.
No news.
I'll be looking for shorts.
I could argue that's the cluster.
Maybe something like that but what's the rest of the award?
Time is it?
27.
Okay.
Chrome with that.
And see me in New York might give us something.
I'm going to choose again today.
Oh.
I'm going to choose one third.
Okay.
That's the continuation in New York.
I can see that this specific setup is inefficient.
Almost gets to break even but almost to break even isn't good enough.
What do I keep noticing about it?
I'm not really sure how to refine it.
Maybe I'll be able to figure it out.
I'm not sure how to do it.
Maybe I can upload an image.
Okay.
You know what I could do?
What I could do is
I'll come back, if it was me and I wasn't recording this, I would record a loom
video of what I wanted to be here.
What we'll do is
I'll be able to record a loom video of what I wanted to be here.
I'm not sure how to do it.
That's the adjustment.
Like that's actually a continuation.
I don't really like the entry.
I would prefer the entry to be lava but then the rest of the wall is heavily
skewed.
Let's try it.
I'm not a huge fan of the entry.
That takes it from 1% to 0.2%.
Could go to break even, to be honest.
No, definitely break even.
That's the setup.
That's the difference.
I'm going to flag that for review as well so I have the context.
That's the setup where the low sweep New York continuation works.
It's when it's contextual.
Let's take a screenshot of that.
I'll take care of that after.
I'm not sure how to do it under the outcome of it but.
That would take some more for Asia low as well.
I just want to basically secure partials even if it does go all the way.
I'll definitely look again back into shorts.
Drawable goods.
I don't really see drawable goods being - I already see drawable goods having
much effect on price.
We actually change character here.
Which means I could probably look at short on the market from around about here
to 15 pip-stop to 12 pip-stop.
We do have existing home sales which I don't really think is that effective.
I can't remember even yet.
Even if we didn't go to break even because this is potentially unmetigated.
Although on the 30 minutes it's debatable.
Let's say we didn't price tags it in and begin trading away like this.
Already at that point you can go to break even off the reaction.
They both end up being break even but still good management.
I can't believe this one didn't hit target.
This is that short.
This is the A lot short.
This 128 one is the prior one.
I'm going to take my break even, isn't it?
I'm going to move the stop loss to here.
Instead of going to break even we're still going to take 0.4% if it comes back
but doesn't kill all at this point.
I can't believe this table level hasn't been hit.
That's ridiculous.
What are we looking for now?
I'm looking for shorts.
I can't believe this level hasn't been traded through.
I'm still looking for shorts.
A whole little bit of minute.
How does that play out?
Does it have one candle?
I guess it's anywhere where not really a poor work.
It's two candles.
That's both break even but I moved my stop to here as well.
Good management.
I can't believe that that trade didn't hit the table.
That's wild.
We did also take profits at logical price levels.
Not just stripping profits off at every level out of fear because a lot of
times price will run to that structural level.
If there's a few in a trade and you get in your trade and you've got your 5R
and there's maybe an old London low here and old Asia low here.
Don't be afraid to just take partials because you're going to expect reactions
from these levels.
You have to also think about how it impacts you psychologically when price, you
're running into a profit and price hits a certain level and then it starts retr
acing.
You need to make sure that you're also set up for kind of ease of psychological
handling when you start seeing these reactions.
You start going to be like, "Oh, I could have closed. Oh, there's all of that."
So just don't be afraid to take profits from structural levels.
Cool.
Price isn't going to run the highs.
Probably not.
Nope.
Cool.
Still looking for shorts.
Wait, we didn't join on those trades.
Okay, this 128 one is this one.
I'm going to flag it for review because I want to use it as context.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Always want to leave notes for yourself to make sure that you're reviewing.
Still inside this price range.
Looking for shorts above here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
If I see this, my execution, 10 times out of 10 is going to be this.
Maybe even this.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The reason I'm saying that is because it tags in sure way.
This is also technically speaking.
That's right.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Don't journal.
Both of these, I didn't.
And I felt like I didn't.
Okay, give me a second.
Let me go back and journal this.
It was a low sweep.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
These ones were quite nice.
All right, I think there was news.
But the news was.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Did I close half?
I did.
Again, here, to the few different levels I could have not taken profits from.
I want to serve them like all of these levels are potential profit takers.
I don't want to strip myself dry to the point there's nothing left to hold to
this target.
See if I take 50% on everything that I'm going to end up basically taking
nothing.
So, what I want to do really is probably ignore this age of session love.
I'm going to do that partial partial partial partial.
See how that plays out.
New York session, what do we have here?
Wednesday the 30th of April.
We have GDP growth rate.
And it's about to hit, but we are stops at break even.
I don't mind holding through that.
That was GDP growth rate.
We also have PC at 10, personal income at 10, personal spending at 10 as well.
But I'll hold through those things.
Because, I mean, stops at break even.
So, even we're going to trade lower, which is my belief.
Oh, we're not.
And news may be a catalyst to support that hypothesis.
Which is, so we can take our next load of partial to that level.
What's the difference between that's one to 12, it's one to 15.
It's not very much different as it.
At this point we have basically nothing left on the table.
And boom.
Nice.
It's a really nice trade.
We're going to take in five bar.
We're going to take in like 10 or 7.5.
Probably not taking around 8% on that trade, which is really nice trade.
It's also the last trade of April, I think.
Yeah, it is cool.
Now we're in May.
So, that's April done.
Really nice April.
That's a London sweep, New York, London sweep Asia.
Point of interest is, I don't know, I don't know how to consider that.
For the same week, session London, trend gender, structure flow, technically
pro trend.
Yeah.
Held through modern news execution window.
Cool.
Let's have a little bit of a look at April in review.
Nice, 38% win rate.
We have a 4.79 profit factor, which is extremely high.
We have a 7, this is crazy.
Our average win to losing trade is 7.8 times more player.
So, for every one we lose, we win 7.78.
Decent win rate, very decent win rate.
It looks at reports in a while.
That's what, February, March, April, that's 3 months, that's a quarter.
It's really nice so far.
Not too much data, but cool.
Still collecting more and more data.
So, that is January, March, April done.